of lives and years of healthy life and
then it says
uh it talks about the importance of uh
taking action in the winter
in comparison to the spring and summer
periods uh act
action to prevent the nhs being
overwhelmed that word again
is even more critical in the winter
months
and it talks about in terms of the loss
of life if action wasn't taken
loss of life in such a scenario are
considered
intolerable for society it talks about
the disruption to wider nhs business
if acute and critical bear care bed
capacity
is breached that would be severe the
report says um
emergency care patients will be unable
to receive the urgent treatment they
need resulting in many further deaths
cancer cream
screenings may need to be postponed
thousands of elective procedures at
surgery
are cancelled or delayed uh talks about
longer term
challenges and then towards the end of
the report those
warnings are repeated again
the health the health effects reach far
beyond the tragic death and suffering
from covid
also come from knock-on implications on
other health services
it's clear restrictions to contain
covert have had major impacts on the
economy
even if it's not possible to forecast
with confidence the precise impact of a
specific change
to a specific restriction mps will no
doubt be critical of that
vagueness if you like and then just
finally again on this
uh occup hospital admin admission and
occupancy rates
they're already much higher than in the
summer it's an escape it's an
inescapable
fact that exponential growth leads to a
situation where the nhs
would become overwhelmed that word again
and there would be insufficient capacity
for those patients
most critically in need of it uh the
corresponding cost to society
of higher death rates is not one that
any government or country
would willingly uh talk uh tolerate and
again the very final paragraph talks
about
we mustn't allow the nhs to be
overwhelmed so that
is the big argument more deaths and
allowing the nhs to become overwhelmed
unless action is taken that is the
argument uh that
we will hear from no doubt from mr
hancock
who's going to be speaking shortly matt
hancock is going
to be joined by professor stephen powers
the national medical director of nhs
england and general
sir gordon messenger he's the head of
operations for the
community testing program and it looks
as though they haven't
started yet they're a minute or two late
yeah um but that's the impact assessment
you were talking about i mean so what
impact
will it have do you think on these mps i
mean is there enough in there is there
anything new in there that
is going to persuade them i think
critics will say no
the hard-line opponents of what the
government is proposing i don't think
will be very
impressed by this they'll say oh we've
heard all this economic stuff before
from the office of budget responsibility
last week
when rishi sunak announced his spending
review
and some of the critics were quite
unimpressed
with michael gove's plea in the times on
saturday
so i don't think it this in itself will
uh
will it will move that many mps now i
was talking to one of the senior rebels
a short time ago he was saying uh
that if the government doesn't come up
with some more assurances
some more help for hospitality in
particular other
sweeteners if you like then that
rebellion is likely to be 60 or 70
if the government does come up with some
promises
which are good enough to buy off some of
the rebels the rebellion could be down
to sort of 40 plus
so we're still looking at a big
rebellion um a lot of
mps are very unhappy uh we've talked
before about mps from kent
mp's from dorset parts of the south of
england where you've got rural areas
uh whether infection rates are low next
to towns or conorbations where they're
higher
leicestershire is another example lower
than leicester we'll leave it there
thank you very much indeed because
matt hancock is about to begin good
afternoon and welcome to today's downing
street coronavirus briefing i'm joined
today by professor steve powers
the national medical director of nhs
england
and general sir gordon messenger the
head of operations for the
community testing program tomorrow night
our national restrictions in england
will come to an end
and subject to the vote in parliament
will return
to the tiered system from wednesday
morning
i know that the national restrictions
have been really tough for some people
but the good news is they've been
working
let me take a moment if i may to run
through some of the numbers
today's study from imperial college
shows that the national restrictions
have brought down
cases by a third over the last week
the average number of positive tests is
now 14
hundred and seventy eight down from a
peak of twenty five thousand
three hundred and thirty one on the
sixteenth
of november today there are fifteen
thousand
seven hundred and twelve patients in
hospital
right across the uk with coronavirus
that is down from 16 612
on the 23rd of november a week ago
in england in the week before the peak
the number of
cases grew by 11 but in the last week
cases have dropped by 30 percent almost
a third this is clearly good news
it shows that the national restrictions
have been successful
and what this means in practice is that
through
everyone's actions in respecting the
national lockdown
and through everything that people have
sacrificed
we've reduced pressures on the nhs we've
brought down the number of coronavirus
cases
we've got this virus back under control
and i want to thank you for that and for
the part that you've played
the effect of the action that we take of
course brings with it
huge challenges too especially for the
hospitality sector
and as the analysis of health economic
and social effects of covert 19 and the
approach to tiering
shows which we've published today
it clearly demonstrates this action is
necessary to avoid a much worse outcome
and we must be vigilant there are still
fourteen thousand seven hundred and
seventy eight
positive cases reported every day and
there are still
those fifteen thousand seven hundred and
twelve people in hospital with covet
and sadly there are still 460 reported
deaths
on average each day this is far too many
but there is light at the end of the
tunnel we know that together we can beat
this
and we've got to stick at it
putting this in technical terms the r
rate is back below 1
but only just when r is below 1
the number of infections falls over time
because on average
each infected person infects fewer than
one
other and for that to happen on average
it's important that lots of infected
people infect no one else at all
this is the central challenge of this
pandemic
and it's made much much more difficult
because about one in three people with
coronavirus
have no symptoms at all but nevertheless
they pass the infection on
to others and that is why even as we
ease these national restrictions
we've got to keep some restrictions in
place
and hence the tiering system so while we
can let up a little
we can't afford to let up a lot
the success of our collective efforts
means that from wednesday
everyone in england even those in tier
three
can have some greater freedoms but we
don't have much headroom
we can't risk letting cases rise again
especially into christmas
and with the flu season around the
corner the prime minister has published
the government's covid winter plan
which sets out the international
restrictions and the steps that we'll
take
to help to bring life back to normal by
spring
but even as we take those steps forward
we must keep our resolve
we've worked so hard and collectively
sacrificed
so much but we can get through this
and i know that hope is on the horizon
in the past fortnight we've made some
really significant progress
on vaccines and the nhs now stands ready
to deploy a vaccine
should one be approved by the uk's
independent regulator
today moderna the american company
formally filed for its vaccine
in america modern has already been
submitting data to
the mhra the uk's regulator for some
time
and as we set out this weekend we've
secured two million further doses
meaning that we in the uk now have
access
to a total of 357 million doses of
seven different vaccines and while we
keep working on a vaccine
we've already built a huge testing
capacity
that we can deploy right now
and i wanted to take a moment to talk
through the next steps on
testing since the start of the pandemic
we've built the biggest testing capacity
in europe
and it means we can use tests to do lots
of things that we couldn't do before
in addition to our symptomatic testing
program and the rapid testing that we're
now deploying in the nhs and across
social care
we have the capacity to do more today we
begin the rollout of our university
student testing program and expand
community testing
and we won't just test people with
symptoms because of this problem
of asymptomatic transmission people who
don't have symptoms but do have
covid transmitting covid to others we're
going to test people who don't have
symptoms as well
this really matters because finding the
positives
by finding the positives we can break
the chain of transmission and stop other
people catching covet
in liverpool where over 300 000 people
both those with symptoms and those
without where they
where that that testing has happened
they've managed to bring the case rates
down by over three quarters
and so on wednesday liverpool will go
into tier
two not tier three
of course i want to see this sort of
success right across the board
so we're rolling out community testing
much more
widely we've been working with those
going into
tier three with colleagues from scotland
wales and northern ireland too
and today with the publication of our
community testing prospectus
we set out the next phase of that work
to give tier three areas a faster way
out of the toughest restrictions
to support them to come down the tears
as has happened in liverpool
we've already received significant
interest from around the country
including from the west midlands red car
warwickshire and medway and others
and this offer is available all across
the uk and will be delivered
in partnership with local authorities in
tier three
areas and with devolved administrations
throughout the country because by using
tests that can turn results around in
under 30 minutes
we can identify and then isolate
people who have covid including
crucially
the about one in three people with covid
who don't have those symptoms
at all but can nevertheless pass the
infection on
because if you have covid without
symptoms
and still infect others that of course
is a silent danger
you wouldn't know that you're risking
lives around you
and so to anybody if you're offered a
test
please take it you might just save a
life the final thing i wanted to say
is that it is all of our responsibility
to keep ourselves safe to keep our
families our friends and our communities
safe
that responsibility is on all of us and
i know that it weighs heavily
we've been carrying it for a long time
now but the light of dawn
is on the horizon it's the moment to
stand
firm until the morning so we can look
back
and see clearly that everything we gave
and everything we did it was not for
nothing
but so we could save lives and build
back better
for everyone and i want to turn to
professor powers to take us through the
latest numbers on
the impact on the nhs thank you
secretary of state and
today i'm going to present just a single
slide it's an update of a slide
that i've shown before which concerns
covid19 hospital inpatients in england
and as you all know as infection rates
rise
so do unfortunately do hospital
admissions for those who are sickest
and of course in a minority of people
also that requires
treatment in our intensive care units
and as i've shown you before
as infection rates have risen during the
autumn from september through october
into november
then usually with a couple of weeks lag
we start to see rises in hospital
admissions and the number of people in
hospital
and you can see in this chart that going
through the autumn
into november we have seen increased
numbers of people in our hospitals in
england
now the national lockdown was introduced
at the beginning of november
and we would expect it would be a couple
of weeks as i've said
before we begin to see the effects of
that
on hospitalizations as the secretary of
state has said
we have the evidence that infection
rates are now falling and have been
falling
during this period of lockdown and we
are now just beginning to see that
translate through into hospital
admissions which have been falling
and into the overall number of people in
hospital which again
in recent days has started to turn the
corner and is now falling
and as you can see stood in english
hospitals at 13
772 yesterday now
beneath this there is some regional
variation in the northeast and the north
west
where infection rates have been falling
from a high
base we have similarly seen early falls
in the number of people in hospital
in the south of the country where
infection rates have been lower but
increasing
we are only just beginning to see some
effects
of the lockdown but it will be the next
week or two as we see those full effects
translate through
but of course what's crucial is that we
see hospital
admissions and hospital patients falling
we're going into winter
the nhs is busiest time we are
continuing
all the elective work that we do and
trying to catch up on the backlog that
was caused by the pandemic
over the spring so it's crucial that we
don't have so many patients in our
hospitals that we cannot do that work
and that's why it's important that
numbers continue to fall and of course
that's why it's important that infection
rates fall so we do
need to see the further effects of the
measures that we all have to follow
and of course everybody in the nhs is
extremely grateful
that the public is complying with those
measures because that is how we can all
support the nhs in its work secretary
state
thank you very much professor paris the
first question by video is from
ella in southampton ella when the tier
system begins this week what are the
rules regarding social distancing
in an established relationship in a tier
2 area
my boyfriend and i are in a long-term
relationship but we live in separate
households
so we're unsure what rules apply to us
can we see each other indoors are we
only permitted to see each other
outdoors despite being in an established
relationship
thank you very much ella the rules about
exactly what is permitted
in each of the tiers is on the gov dot
uk
website and we're also making sure that
it's widely available through
advertising
i start my answer with that because for
everybody watching if you're in a
specific situation then the best thing
to do
is to go and look precisely at the
rules now of course i understand the
impact on people who are in
a long-term relationship and we have
made specific provision
but the general rule for those who are
in a
uh who are in tier two is that it is
the uh the rule of six applies outdoors
including for instance in a private
garden but indoors
you should only be mixing with people
who are in your own
household so i hope that answers the
question and i would urge you to go and
look
on the government website if you've got
any query
on any of the specific rules in any of
the tiers
in which you live the next question from
adrian in worthing which has been
submitted by uh
by text what provision is there for
testing of all students at universities
before they return home for christmas
well this is a great time to ask this
question
adrian because today is the first day
that we're rolling out the widespread
testing of people
who are about to return from university
and we want to make sure that people can
come home from university
but do that in the safest possible way
so there's a program right across
universities
right across the uk to ensure that as
many people
as possible can get a test before they
travel
and this is a a really helpful
contribution
an example of how the expansion in
testing capacity that we've
built up over these last nine months or
so
can have a real world impact and then of
course
there are arrangements in place that if
you're at university your university
will be able to give you the details of
uh for those who test positive who of
course then need to
isolate along with their contacts
but that's uh starting today is there
anything else that you think we should
add
no so thank you agent um that is uh
the the provisions there we've um
and i hope that all students will engage
with this
enthusiastically because uh it's so
important for making sure that people
can get home safely
at the end of this term next question is
from
hugh pim from the bbc hugh
thank you secretary of state testing for
students is voluntary and is not
available to every student
at every university so how effective can
that program be
and a question for steve paris how
worried is the nhs
about a new wave of infections putting
real pressure on the nhs
in january following the relaxation over
christmas
uh thanks hugh so our approach to
testing
is uh that it's voluntary we haven't
made testing
mandatory and maybe i'll bring in a
general messenger on this approach with
the community testing that we're rolling
out
as well with the prospectus that's being
is being launched now
um the um of course our goal
is to get this testing avail made
available to
as many students as possible it is a
huge
logistical exercise i'm very grateful to
the universities right across the uk
who've engaged with us to to help to
make this
happen it is about making things as
safe as possible and anybody
who has a concern about the need to
access testing should in the first
instance speak to their university
because we're doing this in partnership
uh with the uh with the universities i
think it will make
a good difference a good positive
difference
but as i say we haven't made it
mandatory because that brings in all
sorts of other considerations
and we think that it is uh therefore
best done on a voluntary basis
um uh general messenger and then i'll
bring in steve on the second question
so obviously a really important part of
the community testing program is to try
and drive up
participation the higher numbers that we
get
tested then the more effective uh this
regime will be
and and we think that the best way to do
that is to work with the local
communities and the local leaderships
because they're best able to tackle
uh where needs are uh where risks are
and they're best able to tailor their
offer to the local communities that they
serve
so that's right at the heart of this
community testing program
is a partnership that's led from the
local level but supported by
central uh help thanks very much and
steve
on the second question about the new
year uh thank you hugh well well as i
said when i
introduce the data slide it really is
important for the nhs
uh that we uh get infection rates down
and that translates as it does into
taking
pressure off hospitals reducing the
number of admissions
and reducing the number of people in
hospital uh with covid19
and that's for a number of reasons and
i'll say them again
firstly unlike the spring when we were
heading out of winter into the summer
we are now heading into the winter the
nhs is always at its busiest
in january february and into march we
see more infections chest infections
from other
viruses and bugs we see more slips trips
and falls so the pressure on the nhs
builds
so it's crucial going into that period
that we have this under control again
unlike the spring we are continuing as
full-on as we possibly can
with all our routine work uh our
elective work
and we are trying to make sure that we
catch up unfortunately on the backlog
that we
that we had because of the pandemic in
the spring and of course we won
we've always been open for everybody
with emergency conditions with symptoms
for heart attacks and strokes
uh and we need the public to access the
nhs just as they always do
we saw a bit of a drop of that in the
spring we don't want to see that we
we want people to come forward so for
all those reasons it's really critical
uh that we keep infection rates under
control now
clearly christmas is a special time uh
but the nhs always asks people to be
sensible
over christmas and we're confident again
that people will act sensibly once again
over christmas they will use uh the
changing restrictions
sensibly and we
will go into the new year hopefully with
infection rates staying down and falling
and therefore the pressure coming off
the nhs at that critical time of year
thanks hugh next question is from emily
morgan at itv emily
thank you secretary of state um i've got
a question about mass testing
i just wonder how you expect to have the
same success you had in liverpool
if you're not going to give the councils
the same
sort of resources coventry council have
told us that they feel like they've
simply been left to try and work this
out themselves and it will cost them a
million pounds will they get that sort
of money
to be able to do the community testing
you want them to be able to do
well yes in the prospectus that we're
publishing
right now it includes extra funding for
local authorities to do this testing
up to a figure of 14 pounds per test
done so that's quite significant extra
funding that's available across the uk
for councils that want to make this
work on the model of liverpool and i'll
ask
a general messenger to set out more
details of how we can make it work
because this community testing approach
is so important to
finding the cases that we haven't yet
found
and so reducing the the number of
infections
which obviously is critical for
everybody
so first the um we're trying to move
away from the term mass testing i think
this
is about community testing it's about
tailoring it to the needs as i said of
the
of of the local area and that might be
geographically specific or it might be
ethnic community specific um and i
think the secret the secretary state's
right when he says the prospectus which
will
be public from now will set out a great
deal
of support and a great deal of
signposting for what is
on offer to these local authorities
and one could easily see an arrangement
where we're setting up some small
local targeted community testing sites
but equally when a community wants to
target broader swathes of the population
something larger something more sort of
ubiquitous
tackling larger swathes of of the
population it really depends on where
the need is
and will be driven by the local
leadership and the local directors
of uh of public health it it's important
to talk about the workforce here i think
because as you
uh rightly point out liverpool was
delivered primarily by
a military workforce and that
and i'm not speaking uh as part of the
ministry of defence i work for
the health secretary on the community
testing program but i can say with
confidence that cannot be
replicated around the country and
therefore
the military support along with all
other types of central support has to be
targeted where it's needed most and
where it can have
the greatest effect so i have absolutely
no doubt
that the military will continue to play
a really important part in the community
testing program but the baseline
assumption in terms of workforce
generation
is that that will be delivered locally
with considerable support
from the centre and from what i've seen
of a number of local communities there's
great ingenuity already underway
in delivering that workforce they're
accessing the volunteer force they're
working very
innovatively with uh the private sector
and yes of course they've got good
liaison with
local leadership in the the military
so that is our starting assumption as i
say i have no doubt that the military
will play a prominent role but the idea
that it can be a wholesale offer to all
local authorities is simply
undeliverable given uh
what the military uh are doing already
thanks very much andy bell from uh
channel five andy
all right secretary of state thank you
very much
um realistically is there any chance of
any part of england being able to move
down a tier
this side of christmas there's meant to
be a review in a couple of weeks time
isn't it much more likely that anyway
we'll have to wait until well into
january for any chance of moving down
the tier because
we'll have to work out what the effect
of the christmas
relaxation has been uh not necessarily
no
we will we'll look at the data on the
16th
of december and we'll announce the
results of that
review on the 17th of december of course
we've got to take into account that
christmas is
coming up but nevertheless with the case
rates coming down as they are
as i said coming down by almost a third
in the last
week then we will be absolutely
looking at each area and um
seeing what is the right tier for that
area
you know i want to see areas that have
pulled together followed the rules got
the case rate down
like liverpool has over the last month
which has led to it having going into
tier two
i want to see that happening much more
broadly and there are some areas of the
country that i'm
i'm worried about there are some parts
of the country
small parts of the country where the
numbers are still going up so we do have
to be careful and we have to be cautious
but the first review will be on the 16th
of december
we'll look at the whole of england at
that point
and then we'll continue to review
regularly after that
thanks very much uh next question is
from uh jim pickard at the ft
jim secretary of state um
you say today that there's nearly 16 000
people in hospital with
covet can you say what proportion of
those are in hospital because of covid
as opposed to people who are in hospital
for other underlying reasons such as
cancer or they've broken a leg and they
happen to have covered
and that's been picked up and also
nadine zahari the new vaccine minister
has suggested that
people who refuse to get vaccinated
could be not allowed to visit
restaurants bars cinemas and so on
is that kind of stick approach something
that you agree with
uh thanks very much well i'll ask steve
to answer the first one and then i'll
answer the second question
so the vast majority of people when we
have a pandemic and the infection rates
are high
are in because of the direct effects of
covid
we do see people in uh hospital uh with
covid
um when infection rates are high who
have not been admitted because of
covered
so it's a secondary state um highlighted
um
about a third of people have covered
without any symptoms
so we have for some time in the nhs been
testing everybody who gets admitted for
covert
to pick up whether they have it or not
and of course as infection rates
increase in the community then the
chance of picking up asymptomatic
individuals as they come into hospital
uh increases so we certainly do see
cases of individuals who've come into
hospital without covid who then test
positive
and that's why we've got very detailed
infection prevention and control
measures in
we not only test people when they arrive
in hospital we test people after they've
been in
hospital for a few days uh because it is
also possible that when you arrive
uh you may test negative so we're very
uh
careful to ensure that we're testing
people uh on a regular basis in their in
their first week in hospital
um because because that keeps patients
safe it keeps uh staff safe
uh but the important thing of course as
i always say is to get infection rates
down
because the lower the rate in the
community
the less the chance is that you will be
admitted into hospital for some other
condition
and turn out to test positive for covid
and on
on vaccines look our overall approach on
the vaccines is firstly that we do not
plan to mandate
the vaccine we think that by
encouraging the uptake of the vaccine we
will get a
very high proportion of people in this
country and to
um to take up the vaccine because of
course it is
it protects you but it also helps to
protect your loved ones and your
community
on the question of what happens once
you've had the vaccine
now of course in the first instance we
do not yet
have reliable data on whether a vaccine
not only protects you
because which we we do have a high
degree of confidence
uh subject to the mhra that i was
talking about in my comments um we do
have a high degree of confidence that
the
three vaccines so far protect the
person who's been vaccinated but the
impact on whether you transmit
the virus is not as clear
from the data so far and therefore in
the first instance our approach will be
to watch the indicators that we watch
all of the time the case rate the case
rate amongst the over 60s
and the positivity rate and um
to see the impact of that on the of the
vaccine and the vaccine program
on the uh on
on the pandemic now having said that for
a long time now we've been looking at
uh the the the questions that minister
zahawi was
talking about and the question of what's
the impact on the individual in terms of
what they can do and i've talked about
that at
press conferences like these months and
months ago
and so that's what minister zahawi was
referring to
and he is a great appointment and i
think will bring a
huge amount of support and uh
and scrutiny to the rollout of the
vaccine
and i think he's going to do a brilliant
job he's already been working on the
on the vaccine on the the business
department side of the fence
and i'm really delighted that he's
joined the department today
next question is from kate pickles at
the daily mail
thank you we have heard concerns from
the faculty of public health about the
enormous resources required for mass
testing
and the suggestion that it could detract
from the vaccine program
firstly i wondered how you'd respond to
that and how confident you are that the
two things can successfully run
alongside one another
secondly is the expansion of community
testing and admission that test and
trace hasn't worked
as well as you would have liked and how
can you envisage test and trace
changing as a result of this new program
thanks very much well i can reassure you
on both counts
the first thing is that the community
testing program
is a big expansion of what we can do
within nhs test and trace and it's only
because of the work of nhs test and
trace over the last
nine months the the work of the team
that has got these massive new testing
capabilities that allow us to make these
expansions
so that work has been the work of nhs
testing trace has been absolutely
critical in getting us to this point
when we can roll out
such uh such widespread use of the
of the tests for instance today to
university
students and then as general messenger
was saying
more broadly to the community working
with local directors of public health
um on the um on the first
part of the question the key point is
that testing
and vaccination need to run alongside
each other and this has already been
happening
for instance in the vaccine trials we
also tested
repeatedly some of the people's with
people within the trials
to find out if they picked up covert and
that's one of the ways that you can find
out if a vaccine can work
and especially because once you've taken
a vaccine
it still takes some time to
get immunity through the vaccine not
least because you have to have two doses
that it's critical that we have the
testing program running alongside the
vaccine program
and so they are designed to be symbiotic
i'll ask
general messenger to say a little bit
more about this but you know the last
thing i'll say on
it is this um the rollout that we can
announce today
of the community testing program is
a sign of the success of nhs test and
trace
in delivering the massive capability
that we now have
to be able to keep more people safe and
to find this
virus and to get it under control with
the
minimal negative impact on people's
lives that all of these things have
general messenger um well i i'm all of
uh all of three weeks in but uh
my experience thus far absolutely
supports what the secretary of state
says
the importance of alignment with what
test and trace have achieved so far
the vital nature of the alignment with
the vaccine
uh we we're absolutely we have to ensure
that those are
um synchronous and not competitive
i can tell you how supportive colleagues
have been in the vaccine task force and
the test and trace their experience
their skills
their knowledge has been vital as we've
uh as we've looked to build this
community
testing uh proposal so
to me that alignment is there but we're
absolutely certain that we cannot allow
uh each other to disrupt or deflect from
that the important business we're all
doing
thanks very much kate the final question
is from david hughes at the pa david
secretary of state tomorrow mps will
vote on these new tiers arrangements
the impact assessment the government has
published today makes clear that without
restrictions
the nhs could be overwhelmed given that
are your colleagues on the tory benches
who are thinking of voting against these
measures acting irresponsibly
and for general messenger 23 million
people will be going into tier 3 this
week
what sort of proportion of those people
would you expect your community testing
exercise to cover thanks very much
david well i would urge all mps right
across the house
to vote for the tiered system the tiered
system
is has a lower set of restrictions than
the national lockdown in
all three tiers but it's also more
targeted
so that the areas where the prevalence
is lower and the pressure on the nhs is
lower
have fewer restrictions which means that
people can
do more in terms of going about their
their their normal lives
and obviously has a less detrimental
impact on the
economy unfortunately though we do have
to have
the higher tier restrictions and in
particular tier three restrictions in
place
so that we can have confidence that we
can keep getting this
virus down and then keep it under
control
um right across the country
and that way it is the best way to avoid
a third lockdown and it is the most
proportionate way
to take the action that we need to keep
people safe
and to stop the nhs being overwhelmed so
i hope that we get
a very significant proportion of the uh
of mps
from all parties uh voting for the
proposals that we'll put before the
house
tomorrow i don't know professor pass if
you've got anything to add from the nhs
side
and then i'll ask general messenger to
answer the second question no no simply
to reiterate the importance as the nhs
goes into its busiest time of year to
ensure
that infection rates are low and falling
because as sure as nightfall as day that
is
two weeks later unfortunately
more hospital admissions uh more people
in hospital
uh more pressure on nhs services and of
course unfortunately more deaths
and increasingly as we understand
conditions such as long covered
uh more uh long-term health problems for
people so
the key as always is to get infection
rates down
and to ensure that they continue to stay
down
uh thanks very much uh general messages
um
david i don't know how many of those 23
million will be able to to reach because
planning is still
very much uh underway and as i said will
uh
the the nature of this will vary uh from
region to region and from area to area
uh we're alive to the the possibility
that we will not be able to do this all
at once
um but we assess that uh local
authorities are
at varying levels of of preparedness and
readiness uh
to to do this and therefore i can see
this as an offer
that will uh sequence over time uh and
into
january uh and beyond uh the priority
that we accord
uh the levels of support we give will be
based on the infection
rate how long those areas have been
under
harsh restrictions how mature their
plans are
how ready they are to deliver them and
that's the business of the next week or
so is to try and identify
some front runners and and to lean into
support of them so we can have a quick
early impact but as i say i can see this
being sequenced over time
thanks very much the the only thing i'd
add to that is that i'd urge
all those council leaders
director of public health and those in
the devolved administrations who want to
take up this offer that set out in the
prospectus
those within the tier three areas in
england and the da's
with whom we've been working to come
forward and come forward with their
proposals
often they know their communities best
and so we want to work
hand in glove with local directors of
public health with local authorities and
of course with
colleagues and mps who represent those
areas
to make sure that we can use this
community testing program
as effectively as possible to root out
this virus
and also then hopefully to free up
people to be able to do some of the
things that we love and
and that way we can better get through
this together
thanks very much indeed that ends
today's coronavirus briefing from
number 10 downing street
there we are matt hancock the health
secretary there um
quoting the research that he says shows
uh the lockdown that's just
ending has worked he said it had brought
down
cases by almost a third and that he said
was good news and means pressure on the
nhs had been
uh reduced and that the virus he said
was back under control
the r8 he said was back uh below one and
he said that was the success of
collective efforts
and it means some areas can have more
freedoms but
we cannot relax it is not the moment
to relax he said it is the moment to
stand firm
and he said the light of dawn is on the
horizon we'll talk to uh
john craig in just a moment about that
news conference just a little bit of
breaking news first and it is that the
british government has uh
decided not to order an immediate public
inquiry into
the north belfast solicitor pat for
newton's
shooting dead by loyalist paramilitaries
in collusion with the state back in 1989
that's according to the
northern ireland secretary brandon
lewis and the family
have been reacting to our correspondent
stephen murphy
about that decision no public inquiry or
no immediate public inquiry
and the family have told stephen murphy
that they've been told that the police
service of northern ireland the
ombudsman investigations must
uh run their course and uh john fanucan
has told uh
sky news that that was an insult and
less
than a sop and we'll have more on that
decision by uh brandon lewis
uh just a little later let's go back
though now to uh
john craig and back to matt hancock and
uh
well i suppose it was a clear message in
some ways the the virus is back under
control but let's not ruin it
yes he began by talking about that and
right at the end when he was asked
if he had a message for those
conservative mps uh voting against the
government
tomorrow he was saying actually that
some of the tier system is
less restrictive than the national
lockdown but
as you've said right at the beginning he
went through all the reasons why
they had to continue with these
restrictions one point he said
we can afford to let up a little but we
cannot afford to let up a lot
and he said i know we can beat this and
we've got to
stick at it now and he also
talked about um testing and uh following
on from liverpool
300 000 tests there he talked about
going on to test people without
symptoms as well as those who have uh if
you've got uh
um and you if you if you have the uh
virus you can infect others
he called it the silent danger uh then
we came on to questions
um a rather a rather sad question from
uh ella from southampton uh i'm
wondering when she can meet up with her
boyfriend but they don't live together
and they were afraid there was no good
for no good news for ella from
the health secretary there talks about
the rule of six and so on
uh you can't meet inside a household and
then
the second half of that briefing we
heard quite a lot
from someone who i think is a new face
at these briefings
now that's general sir gordon messenger
now he's a former vice chief of the
defense staff
and he's been put in charge of testing
and
he was quite candid in many of his
answers uh perhaps unlike the
politicians doesn't
make such quite bold promises um
he was warning that they can't repeat
the exercise that they've had in
liverpool
where large numbers of soldiers have
been helping out
all over the country that would be
undeliverable he said
um but he did say that that
that obviously that they are going to
try and extend this as much as possible
um then um from from professor stephen
powers we had the warnings
uh that we've seen in this government
document the impact assessment
about the pressure on the nhs in january
and february
where he talked in very monosyllabic
words
talked about the great risks of bugs
trips
uh trips slips and falls and then
finally there was a question about
a warning from nadim zahawi the new
vaccines minister
about how people who didn't or refused
to have a vaccine
might be barred from visiting
hospitality and so on
we didn't really get an answer from mr
hancock on that
but clearly uh what mr zahawi has been
saying is that
perhaps that he's suggesting that
establishments if you haven't got some
sort of certificate or some sort of
proof you've had the vaccine
you might not be allowed entry so that
is something i think we'll hear a lot
more about
but uh quite an optimistic tone from mr
uh
hancock in terms of the numbers that he
mentioned at the beginning
but the message as ever stick at it
can't afford